à l'ong fait divers dans la sphère de
l'assassinât tragique et sordide du
petit grégory une partie de l' enquête
est désormais à refaire puisque la cour
d'appel de nancy a décidé d'annuler
plusieurs éléments du dossier jugé non
conforme à la procédure comme par
exemple la manière dont ont été
conduites les expériences graphologique
cela dit le juge d'instruction qui
mènent enquête reste en charge du
dossier est l'assassin présumé bernard
laroche demeure lui en prison
isabelle bechler nous remet en mémoire
l'ensemble des événements depuis
l'assassinât du petit garçon il ya
maintenant deux mois
depuis quelques mois pourtant les deux
corbeaux qui s'acharnait sur les
villemin et leurs familles ont cessé
leurs menaces quand grégory 4 ans est
enlevée le 16 octobre et retrouver noyés
comme un petit chat le soir même dans la
vologne
le lendemain une lettre anonyme bien
signé l'assassinât
le pire c'est que tout le monde pense de
l'assassin qui fait partie de la famille
tout le monde va ses pieds dans la
douleur des obsèques
les gendarmes ont déjà démarré l'enquète
tous azimuts dans cette famille
tentaculaire on va interroger tous les
adultes et faire faire des dictées à
plus de 80 personnes pour tenter de
trouver ce qui aurait pu accumuler haine
et jalousie au point de s'en prendre à
l'enfant pendant quinze jours on écarte
tour à tour plusieurs suspects avant de
s'arrêter le 31 octobre sur bernard
laroche et sa femme et ils vont
ressortir libres de leur garde à vue
normand soupçonné parce que
j'avais une écriture qui ressemblait à
celle du corbeau tanger sous pli je
m'applique c'était pas moi j'ai la
conscience tranquille et n'ont pas pu
prouver
c'était moi seules les analyses
graphologiques désigne bernard laroche à
ce stade de l'enquêté
et c'est loin d'être suffisant pour
l'incarcérer même si le juge est
convaincu d'avoir cerné le coupable
de plus la roche un alibi muriel sa
belle soeur de 15 ans mais muriel va
craquer elle va dire qu'elle est allée
avec lui chercher grégory ses aveux vont
permettre au juge d'inculper et
d'incarcérer laroche puis protestera
toujours de son innocence 6 novembre
nouveau coup de théâtre
muriel se rétracte bernard ils s'en vont
freiner sans jamais techno pour frère
aussitôt les avocats de bernard laroche
demande sa mise en liberté reproche à
l'anc est de ne s'intéresser qu'à leurs
clients
la chambre d'accusation ne l'entend pas
ainsi liberté refusée
un rejet de demande de mise en liberté
ne signifie pas qu une culpabilité est
démontrée
la bataille juridique se poursuit
aujourd'hui ce sont quatorze pièces du
dossier dont les expertises en écriture
qui sont annulés par cette même chambre
d'accusation le juge devra en demander
de nouvelles à lépanges la vie continue
tant bien que mal pour les parents de
grégory leur maison déserte est mise en
vente
une seule chose les soulagerait un peu
c'est que l' enquête aboutisse